yeah there's a very profound question
about the nature of our political system
that means that we got at the last
election a choice between jeremy corbyn
and boris johnson
i think any system which ends up giving
a choice between two people like that
is the people people to lead is
obviously a system that's gone
extremely extremely badly wrong there's
so many
thousands and thousands of wonderful
people in this country who could provide
better leadership than either of those
two
and there's obviously something terribly
wrong with the political parties
if that's the best that they can do it's
also the case
that i don't exclude myself from this
in any sensible rational government
it is completely crazy
that i should have been in such a
senior position in my personal opinion
i'm not smart
i've not built great things in the world
it's just it's completely
crackers that someone like me should
have been in there just the same as
crackers the boris johnson
was in there and that the choice of the
last election was jeremy corbyn it's
also
the case that there are wonderful people
inside the civil service there are
brilliant
brilliant officials all over the place
but the system
tends to weed them out from senior
management jobs
and the problem in this crisis was very
much
lines led by donkeys over and over again
with great people
on the ground doing things as i said
this brilliant young woman jen allen
she wasn't the top person in gds you
know
there were great people further down the
hierarchy who did brilliant things
but the leadership people like me and
the prime minister
and the secretary of state for health we
let down the people on the front line
and we let down the those those
excellent officials as well and we all
should be asking you guys in the
political parties need to ask yourselves
what is it about your parties that give
choices like
johnson versus corbett and we have to
ask what is it about whitehall
that promotes so many senior people who
are completely out of their depth